c'est lamentable salama vous savez qu'il
faut il faut la suivre
quitte à regarder ses fesses oui mais ça
veut dire qu'on sait qu'elle va tomber
alors ça veut dire que voilà oui enfin
c'est ça bon alors au cinéma oui vaut-il
mieux essayer d'ouvrir lentement un
bonbon ou bien il y allait d'un coup sec
pour que ça fasse le moins de bruit
possible et bien au cinéma c'est très
simple il faut pas manger de bonbons
parce qu'on n'est pas au restaurant les
jours à contis passerelle anglais un
jour alain resnais tedo cinéma est il
allé voir un film je pas lequel est
devant lui avec deux dames qui parlait
alors elle parle elle parle elle par les
puits abandonnés la lumière baisse
et puis la lumière s'éteint qu'il rideau
s'ouvre et puis le générique commence
elle continue elle continue à parler
alors à l'aréna qui est très poli ne dit
rien et puis un moment donné la première
image du film apparaît il ya deux
acteurs qui se regardent ils les bonnes
femmes continuent de parler alors un
moment donné très poliment il redit
mesdames et mesdames est-ce que vous
pouvez vous taire parce que le film est
commencée et à ce moment là il ya une
des deux âmes qui s'est retournée et
qu'il est bergman est qui et qui lui a
dit mais monsieur ils ne disent rien
alors tiens leçons de savoir-vivre
vaut-il mieux insulté un postier qui
vous fait attendre où une employée de la
sécu qui vous a oublié pour insulter
personne franchement dans un bus
vaut-il mieux laisser sa place à une
jeune femme enceinte moche ou à une
vieille dame séduisante coûté pas moins
qu'une seule place folle cédé à l'une
des deux points à la voilà peut-il mieux
montrer sa déception de ne pas avoir eu
de molière ou de ne pas avoir eu de
césar vous montrez aucune déception
parce que je suis bien placé pour en
parler en ayant eu quelques-uns les
molières les césar c'est absolument
délicieux c'est comme une bonne critique
ça fait du bien comme ça quand on se
retourne sur son passé en dix ans une
certaine époque les gens de mon métier
mon reconnu mais d'une certaine manière
ils peuvent vous reconnaître aussi sans
césar et sans mollir vaut-il mieux
savoir mauvais au savoir-vivre faut
savoir vivre savoir mourir ça sert à
rien parce que ça à temps tout le monde
et on n'apprend pas la mort la mort ça
s'apprend pas ça peut se douter ça peut
se craindre ça peut faire du mal peut
être douloureux mais ça ne s'apprend pas
la vie par contre ça c'est absolument
fondamental le seul petit bruit de nous
qui restera ce sera la manière dont on
aura vécu
je vis
je pense à un truc leur temps autant que
vous êtes là vous allez me faire par
exemple un beau c'est lamentable comme
ça je l'aurais en stock
serge tu 1 2 3 c'est lamentable mais
c'est lamentable bien est-ce qu'il me
faire un
c'est formidable non ces remarques à ce
sera plus vous ça ces remarques faites
moi assez remarquable ça j'aurai les
deux c'est remarquable merci de vos
vidéos chandler bon là mais parce que
vous n'êtes pas venir non plus toutes
les semaines pour dire ses remarques à
bout c'est lamentable
je vous remercie
ça vous évite de vignes après faire
autre chose voilà c'est ça comme ça où
je fais potiche même quand je suis pas
là c'est quoi merci bien